this video is sponsored by cross out a
free-to-play vehicle action game and as
a bonus for registering through our link
below you'll get a selection of three
weapons or a van cabin for free
looking back on humanity's achievements
you can pinpoint certain landmark
moments that changed the world forever
one such moments was undoubtedly the
birth of the automobile which like rail
transport before is and aviation after
completely revolutionized how humans
moved around many people deserve credit
for this achievement as you're about to
find out the concept of the first car in
the world is by no means a settles
matter but the lion's share of the
accolades go to Karl Benz who designed
and built what is regarded by many as
the first true automobile they say that
behind every great man there is a great
woman and perhaps there is no better
example than Bertha Benz she was there
to support her husband through thick and
thin enjoying the highs together and
using her own money to get him back on
his feet during the lows then of course
there was her iconic road trip which
solidified the car as a practical
machine
Bertha's daringness combines with Cole's
engineering genius ensured that people
finally looked at the car as some things
that could actually be used in
day-to-day life we've come a long way
since then but it would be completely
fair to say that the automotive industry
would not be what it is today if it
weren't for Karl Benz
Karl Benz sometimes spelled with AC
instead of a K was born Karl Friedrich
valiance on November the 25th 1844 in
the German town of Muehlberger which
today is a borough of Karlsruhe in the
state of bada Ruttenberg his name was
valiance because his father Johann Georg
Benz and his mother Josephine valiance
were not married at the time of his
birth however they did in fact marry a
few months later and the baby became
Carl Frederick Benz Johan Benz was a
locomotive driver but he died in an
accident when Carl was only 2 years old
this left the family in dire financial
straits but the mother did her best to
ensure a good education for her son
young Hall soon followed in his father's
footsteps and studied engineering bands
from an early age proved to be a
prodigious students in fact when he was
just 19 years old Carl Benz graduated
with a degree in mechanical engineering
from the University of Karlsruhe this
was in 1864 and yet it would be a while
before Benz finally found his vocation
in life he spent the next seven years
trying out various jobs with multiple
construction and engineering firms
throughout Germany but he found them all
to be unsatisfying at the same time he
became an avid bicycle rider and enjoyed
tinkering with them fantasizing about a
similar vehicle that would be motorized
in 1871 Carl Benz started his first
business he partnered with a mechanic
named August Ritter and opens an iron
foundry and mechanical workshop in
Mannheim the company was not successful
and within a year it was struggling
financially
fortunately for Benz he soon found a
better partner one who would have an
enormous impact on his life and the
developments of the automobile and that
would be his bride-to-be
Bertha ringer
Berthe ringer had been born at a time
when it was firmly believed that women
had no business with scientific and
mechanical matters and that even just
exerting their brains would decrease
their ability to have children certainly
not the case here though Carl and Bertha
would go on to have five children
together and yet even when she was young
Bertha took an interest in engineering
according to a particularly
heartbreaking legend she became
determined to show the world that women
were capable of achieving great things
after reading her family's Bible one day
and finding an entry that said
unfortunately only a girl again
written by her father on the day she was
born whether this story is true or not
the elder mr. ringer did leave a
substantial dowry after working as a
successful carpenter all his life
besides oh wealth Bertha ringer was also
a beautiful and clearly intelligent
woman when she reached marrying age she
had a long list of potential suitors to
choose from and yet fate led a poor -
Evald engineer named Karl Benz to share
the same coach's birther and her mother
during an excursion in 1869 the two
started talking and as soon as Karl
brought up a horseless carriage he was
working on he captured Bertha's interest
and soon enough her heart despite
warnings and admonishments from her
family Bertha's mind was made up
Karl was the man she wanted to be with
for the rest of her life the couple
married in 1872
Bertha's support of her husband was
unwavering her first act was to use part
of a dowry to buy out Auguste Ritter's
share in Benzes company the rest of the
money was used to keep the business
afloat while Karl worked on new patents
although Benz was undoubtedly a genius
engineer and designer nobody could ever
accuse him of being a shrewd businessman
Benzes first great achievement was his
stationary gasoline two-stroke engine he
was inspired by the work of an earlier
German engineer Niklas Otto who created
the first four-stroke engine in 1861
Benz received a patent for his invention
in 1880 and went on to add improvements
such as an engine speed regulation
system and ignition via a battery system
this new device of Benz managed garner
interest from banks and businessmen who
wanted to invest because he needed the
capital to grow his company Ben's
converted his business into a joint
stock company named gas motor and fabric
Mannheim in 1882 this did not work as he
had hoped it would
after all the agreements were completed
Benz ended up only owning 5% of the
company more importantly he did not have
a significant say in how the business
was run his partners had differing
notions on what products to design and
sell and the engineers ideas were often
ignored not happy with this arrangement
carbons left corporation the following
year undeterred Benz looked to start a
new company but this time he searched
for more amenable partners he found them
in max rose and Friedrich Wilhelm
Eslinger two men who owned a bicycle
repair shop in Mannheim together they
established the benzene company arrange
gas motor and fabric better known today
as benzene Koch the business focused on
manufacturing engines and proved to be
profitable growing to 25 employees in a
short amount of time the newfound
success eased the pressure off Ben's a
little bit and allowed him to indulge in
his passion project building an
automobile using his engine now if you
want to build your own automobile but
don't have the resources or the skills
to do that in the real world well let me
tell you about today's sponsor cross out
a game where you build your own vehicle
and pit it against others in combat
let's jump over to the computer hello
everybody and welcome to cross sounds
this is not only vehicle shooter game
all vehicles are player made so I just
made this thing from the ground up well
we're loading the game now so you'll be
able to see it in just a second but it's
got a rocket beast is on the back I was
playing for ages with four wheels and
then I realized I could turn really fast
over but six years on that I watch this
that's a good turn that's a good turn
right there this game is free to play
across all major platforms PS 4x
this one I'm playing on PC let's get
this got a kill assist not quite the
glorious victory I was hoping for
that's right enemy destroyed Oh although
I have taken some damage and still
managed to work current glad I put some
extra wheels now you got a huge arsenal
part so let's just have a look at these
other players and you can see like
everyone makes their own craft this
guy's got three guns on the front he's
got two wheels at the back and I see
someone with yeah this guy's got his
hover things going on so you just hovers
around Elise Eames later the coward come
on Helen get back to the game what are
you playing it and then you can choose
like I had a chainsaw in front of my guy
there's Rams machine guns shotguns
autocannons all sorts of stuff this
guy's invisible now it's PvP games
there's PvE raids you can play
cooperatively if you want to loads a
great stuff going on like I say is
totally free you can get started whether
you got a PC ps4 Xbox one whatever you
like you're good to go
and let's get back to the show so yes
that's cross out it's free to play easy
to get in to register through the link
below and you'll get a selection of
three weapons or a van cabin for free
and let's get back to the video in 1885
Karl Benz finished his magnum opus the
Benz patent motive Argan it was a
two-seater vehicle we had three wire
spoke wheels and a single cylinder
gasoline-powered engine that formed a
single units within the chassis and was
capable of producing 0.75 horsepower and
reaching top speeds of 10 miles per hour
other bells and whistles on the vehicle
included a controlled exhaust valve an
automatic intake slide and high-voltage
electrical vibration ition with spark
plug in January 1886 Benz received
patent number three seven four three
five for his vehicle powered by a gas
engine or the birth certificate of the
automobile as it came to be known later
in July Benz drove his car in public for
the first time so was this the first car
in the world well for the sake of
simplicity it is generally regarded as
the first automobile but that question
is difficult to answer because it
depends on what your definition of an
automobile is the most of Argan
definitely does not look like a car of
today but it was the first vehicle of
its kind to be made commercially of a
able to the public Benzes machine has
another advantage over designs that came
before it and then it managed to
function without exploding or falling
apart while in operation which was a big
plus the truth is that some people
regard an automobile are simply a
self-propelled vehicle powered by some
kind of engine and in that case we have
to go back even farther than horseless
carriages French inventor Nicholas
Joseph kunio invented a full-sized
mechanical lion vehicle called the
Fatiha Ave yeah back in 1767 they played
over eight thousand eight hundred pounds
and was powered by steam in 1807 another
Frenchman named Isaac de Rivaz designs
an experimental vehicle powered by
hydrogen gas Robert Anderson was a
Scottish inventor who created an
electric carriage sometime during the
1830s which was powered by
non-rechargeable batteries in 1867
Belgium Jean Josef Etienne Lenoir built
a vehicle powered by an atmospheric gas
engine German secret Marcus did
something similar a few years later by
combining a handcart with an atmospheric
engine he did keep improving his design
and ended up with something that could
be called a car but this happened in
1888 after the Benz patent Motorwagen we
should also mention the French team of
Edouard Delamar to boot oval and
assistant Leon Mallon Dean who started
work on a vehicle with an internal
combustion engine and a three-wheeled
chassis back in 1883 some people do
argue that delamare boot oval might
deserve some of the accolades usually
given to Karl Benz but the truth of the
matter is that his vehicle never
functioned well enough to go into
production last but not least we should
include Gottlieb Daimler and vilhelm
Maybach who are working on their own
automobile independently of Karl Benz at
the same time about 60 miles away they
finished the Daimler motor coach a
couple of months after at the Benz
motive Argan as you can see the question
of who built the first car is a tricky
one and it doesn't really have a
universal answer although we can
generally agree that the Benz patent
Motorwagen was the first practical
automobile and therefore set in motion
the nascent stages of an industry that
would grow to become one of the biggest
in the world
after the original motive argan came out
Ben's immediately went back to work too
new and improved models of his
automobile were released in the next
couple of years but it seems like the
rest of the world did not share Carl and
Bertha's vision for an automotive future
as demands for the motive Argan was not
particularly high the Benz engine still
sold nicely but what would be the point
of buying a whole vehicle up until then
these kinds of self powered machines
were only used in trials over short
distances and still needed mechanics to
be on hand
there was no practicality to them
whatsoever not to mention the fact that
they were expensive and would have only
been accessible to the rich elite they
were not interested though because they
considered something like the motive
Argan to be too loud and messy not very
gentlemanly what the car needed was a
bit of good PR like we said before Carl
Benz was at his best when he was getting
his hands dirty in the workshop
fortunately for him Bertha had a better
mind for marketing and she realized that
they needed some kind of stunts not only
to garner publicity for their new
product but also to show people that it
had a purpose
therefore in the early hours of the hot
August day in 1888 Bertha Benz jumps
behind the wheel of a benz patents
motive Argan number three and embarked
on one of the most important automotive
journeys in history the first
long-distance trip by car
Bertha did not tell her husband of her
plan she also did not inform the
authorities so technically what she did
was illegal
Bertha recruited her teenage sons
Richard and Eugen to tag along for the
ride and they left Mannheim in the
morning on the pretense of going to
visit her mother in for time this was 66
miles away and while that might sound
like a routine trip nowadays it was
significantly longer than any journey
that had ever been previously attempted
in any kind of motorized carriage
moreover birth that contend with
problems that nobody else had to deal
with starting with the fact that there
were no roads suitable for cars back
then she had to follow wagon tracks for
most of the way and even went on ancient
Roman roads in some parts another
problem was the fuel as the motive
argent needed to refuel every 15 to 20
miles and obviously there were no gas
stations anywhere her automobile used a
fuel called
which was a petroleum-based solvent that
could be bought pharmacys Bertha made a
stop in Weis Larkin's paid a visit to
the local apothecary looking to buy ten
liters of liked rhyme this startled the
elderly kam has to saw a young woman
with stains on her dress and naturally
assumed that she wanted to use the
solvent kina clothes he offered her a
one liter bottle noting that that would
be sufficient but of course Bertha
didn't want to clean her clothes in the
end she purchased three liters of Lyon
which was all the chemist had in stock
but since then that pharmacy in wife's
lockers branded itself as the first fuel
station in the world it even has a
monuments of Bertha and her two sons in
front of it other problems is included
needing to refill the water tank
regularly but chain that broken tap to
be fixed by a blacksmith the leather
brake pads that wore out and had to be
replaced by shoemakers and even the
occasional steep hill where the boys had
to get out and push the car
Bertha even showed off her own know-how
on occasion using her garter to plug a
leak and happens to clear up clogged
valves the 66 mile journey took over 12
hours but Bertha Richard and Eugen made
it to four times safely more importantly
the trip achieved its goal many people
took notice some were even frightened to
the point of prayer by the crazy woman's
speeding through their towns and a
smoking monster almost overnight
everyone heard of the Benz patent motive
argan and in case they missed the first
time they had another chance soon
because after a few days Bertha and the
boys returned home in the same car but
on a different reaped more ever birth or
even identified a few ways of improving
the Benz car such as adding a new gear
for climbing hills in 2008 this 120 mile
long return trip from Mannheim to 4-time
was declared a European route of
industrial heritage and there is a
parade of antique cars that follows it
every two years in celebration of
Bertha's iconic voyage
Bertha's trip was the turning point for
the automobile industry but especially
for the Benz company of course we were
still decades away from the car becoming
the standard method of transportation
but people started to see it not as some
kind of oddity but as the future the
Benz patent motive Argonne went on sale
in 1888 and bizarrely it sold better in
France than in Germany again this was
down to call Benzes lack of business
acumen because of this transactions were
slow in his native country in France
however the marketing was done by a
prison engineer and a bicycle
manufacturer named Anil Raja who had
more of a flashier Manship Raja was
already a successful distributor of
Ben's engines and he had received sole
agency rights to sell Ben's cars in
France some of his creative marketing
ideas included showing off his motive
Argand model 3at
the 1889 World's Fair and signing up the
car for racing events there was some
tension between the two because Raja
made an effort to minimize Benzes role
in the development of the car and
increase his own he gave out leaflets to
prospective buyers that described the
automobile not once mentioning the name
Ben's he made special Raja badges that
he fitted to the cars that he sold and
he made sure that the vehicles he raced
were all referred to as Raja cars even
with his shenanigans the Benz company
continued to grow and had to relocate to
a bigger production Factory by 1890 it
had become the second largest engine
manufacturer in Germany and was poised
to grow even more after the addition of
two new partners Friedrich von Fisher
and Julius guns as for Cole he cared
about the one thing he always cared
about the engineering throughout the
1890s he came up and patented several
new innovations most notably the double
pivot steering planetary gear
transmission and to the flat engine with
a boxer configuration which was better
known as the contra engine back then at
the recommendation of his partners Karl
designs a new and improved automobile
the benz Victoria which went on sale in
1892 however it was his follow up design
the benz Velo that really took off and
came to be regarded as the world's first
large-scale production car by the end of
its sales run in 1902
over 1200 vale o--'s had been sold and
while karl was looking for new way
to use as increasingly powerful engines
he also invented the motorized bus
originally capable of seating eight
people
although benz and co was successful it
was feeling the heat from its number-one
competitor Daimler motor and gazelle
shaft dmg headed by Gottlieb Daimler and
Phil hell Maybach diner
away in 1900 but just one year later may
bark designed and produced his crowning
achievements the Mercedes 35 HP our
previous cars still mostly looked like
coaches with engines fitted to them this
was a vehicle we would consider to
resemble a modern idea of a car not to
mention that it was the first automobile
branded as a Mercedes and in case you're
wondering where the name Mercedes came
from it was named after the daughter of
Austrian businessman and mill Jelinek
who not only Commission's the 35 HP but
was very hands-on in his development and
specifically requested certain
improvements that ensured the car became
a landmark mermans in automotive history
to counter their competition the Benz
company brought in some French designers
to help with the new models this angered
Karl Benz who resigned his position in
1903 although he still remained on the
board of directors his sons Richard and
Eugen soon followed suit and they
founded a new company called Benson in
1906 headquartered in Loddon back they
searched for new markets and found
success in England where their cars
became quite popular as taxis because
the Benz family had enough capital by
this point they never issued public
stocks in the new company so they could
retain complete ownership of it then
songs lasted until 1923 although Karl
Benz liquidated his shares and retired
in 1912 leaving the business in the
hands of his sons during the 1920s the
German economy plummeted and all
industries were hurting including the
automotive one in order to survive Benz
and Co and dmg signed an agreement of
mutual interest in 1924 the automakers
combines their production and marketing
efforts while still retaining their
individual brands in order to save on
costs this did not last long and two
years later they merged into formed
Daimler Benz immediately this deal was a
success as their sales tripled in 1920
seven all the new vehicles were labeled
as mercedes-benz a brand this is still
today as popular as it's ever been
Carl stayed on the board of directors
for the rest of his life he died on
April the 4th 1929 at the age of 84 in
his home in Lautenberg Bertha kept on
living in the same home until she passed
away on May the 5th 1944 they both live
long enough to see the industry that
they helped create and dedicated their
entire lives to grow thrive into one
which became indispensable to humanity
so I really hope you enjoyed that video
if you did please do hit that thumbs up
below and do support us by supporting
our fantastic sponsor cross out who I'm
gonna link to you below and thank you
for watching